David, did you solve this problem?
>> So just like the original state,
there could be five moves
that come out of this.
Two of the moves we can
already say are illegal.
Moving two guards would have more
prisoners than guards on the left.
And moving one guard and
one prisoner would end up with
too many prisoners on the right.
So we don't include those states.
Then our three legal moves are to
move one prisoner, two prisoners,
or one guard.
But, now I notice that this state is
actually identical to this state.
Like we said before,
once we're in a state,
we don't really care how we got there.
So going back to an earlier
state is not a productive move.
So, we can rule this out
as an unproductive move.
Similarly, this state is
the same as this state.
So we can rule this out as
an unproductive move as well.
That leaves us with only
one legal productive move
that can follow from the previous state.
>> That is a very good point, David.
So this representation is a good
representation for this problem,
because it is making all the constraints
of the problem solving explicit.
So that we can quickly
compare states and
say, which moves are productive and
moves are not productive?
>> I can tell you that when I tried to
solve this problem on my own, it took me
a while because I didn't recognize
the fact that I kept going around in
a circle because I didn't realize I kept
coming back to the exact same state.
>> In fact, David,
most of us have the same difficulty.
So the power of this semantic network
as a representation is arising
because it allows us to
systematically solve this problem,
because it makes all the constraints,
all the objects, all the relationships,
all the moves, very explicit.